So let's now revisit the topic of cache
misses when we have coherence going on.
We have seen that caches have 3 C's,
3 types of misses.
Compulsory misses,
conflict misses and capacity misses.
Remember the compulsory misses,
we have them because we're accessing
the block for the first time.
So, because it was never in the cache,
we have to have this miss.
Capacity misses we have because
the block doesn't fit in a cache of this
size.
And conflict misses we have because the
cache doesn't have enough associativity.
With coherence, another C, we can now
have a cache miss caused by coherence.
For example, when we read something,
somebody writes it, and
we want to read it again, that would
not be a miss except for coherence, so
we call this type of
a miss coherence miss.
So remember that there
is actually four Cs.
The three we have seen before,
and coherence miss.
There are really two types
of coherence misses.
What we have seen so
far is the true sharing type of miss
which occurs when different
cores access the same data, so
naturally we have to perform
coherence and thus have some misses.
So for example if we read A and
then write A and then read A again.
There are some misses necessary in order
to get the right behavior for the reads.
But these were all
happening on the same data.
There is another type of coherence miss,
called false sharing,
which occurs when different
cores access different data, so
there shouldn't be any coherence
messages because of that.
Except that these data items
are in the same block.
So it's called false sharing because,
really, there is no true data sharing,
but
as far as coherency's concerned, we do
everything at the relative cache blocks.
So two items being in the same block
makes them behave like the same item,
as far as coherency's concerned.